hey guys it is the 21st of October my
name is Jess and this is my lovely
peaceful priced route that the u.s. got
a while back has now made its way over
to Europe and Australia going forward
the 500 gigabyte model of the
PlayStation 4 will cost 480 bucks in
Australia which is markedly cheaper than
its launch price of 550 dollars in
Europe the PS bulb will now cost 350
euro or 300 pounds down from 400 euro
and 350 pounds
Sony has said that the console now
presents its best ever value just in
time for the holiday season YouTube are
introducing a no ads version of their
site called a huge shewbread where you
can pay $10 a month to avoid commercials
YouTube red which may not have been the
best choice in name will also enable you
to watch videos offline or in the
background and other apps run on your
device in addition to that you'll get a
Google Play Music subscription and
normally goes for $10 a month on its own
it's worth noting that you won't get
access to the site's library of
on-demand paid content with your
subscription and you could still end up
watching ads if creators put them in
their videos that said content creators
like PewDiePie and CollegeHumor asked
later to create programming that will be
exclusive to YouTube read the service
opens on October 28th and you can try it
out with a 1 month free subscription
it's just those shoes
finally he be soft have pledged a strong
stance of Independence in spite of a
significant and unwanted investment from
entertainment giant Vivendi so then he
bought a 6.6 percent stake in Ubisoft
which it turns out you me aren't so keen
on the Vandy's portfolio currently
includes Universal Music Group and they
are the ex owners of
visioned elicit so we separated from the
company as part of a buyback process in
2013 according to an email obtained by
games industry international Ubisoft CEO
Yves Colima has called the investment
unsolicited and unwelcome adding our
intention is and has always been to
remain independent a value which for 30
years has allowed us to innovate to take
risks create beloved franchises for
players around the world and which has
helped the company grow into the leader
it is today he also said that if his nd
takeover could hurt the company's brand
as the media giant has a history of
aggressively pursuing companies within
the entertainment sector moon is out in
that comment section what you think of
the YouTube subscription plan you can
add the GameSpot we've got a brand new
full at full video and a Legend of Zelda
Triforce heroes review that is
everything I have for you today as
always let me know what you cared about
and I will catch again soon